we've seen grid legends and now it's
time for a
different breed of legend
two years ago apex legends came out of
nowhere and now 100 million players and
17 legends later it just
keeps getting bigger we've got more
modes more maps more platforms for play
and of course more legends
so what's next for apex well today
we have answers ladies and gentlemen
i give to you apex legends
emergence
change i see it in everything
i see it in a boy rocked by tragedy
transform his pain and defy
reality
i see it in the warrior who must choose
between their new life
and the annihilation of their home
i see it in a girl tortured by revenge
embrace hope when love awakens her heart
i see it in me a boy born
under a bad woman turn his tail
into a legend
change is relentless
but that does not mean it cannot be
beautiful
empty comfort
nothing lasts forever
[Music]
you must adapt
surrender
and embrace your true nature
know that you are not alone
change comes for us all
[Music]
but this chaos has purpose
all of us thrown together
so the flame can burn its brightest
change fight it
and fall
accept it and rise above
wow i'm standing here like slack-jawed
watching this
because there's so much to unpack from
that trailer so let's go ahead and meet
the man with all the answers
apex game director chad grenier
so happy to have you here chad thanks
austin happy to be here uh before we get
started
and get into it i want to give a shout
out to the amazing developers at respawn
hey all right well a subset of them uh
if you love apex it's because of these
amazing developers that are
working hard uh creating apex legends
for us
well big love to the whole respawn team
especially whoever came up with lifeline
cause that's
my girl but okay there's a lot for us to
talk about but you know i'm geeked about
seer so can you tell us some more about
his abilities
i saw this man stare through walls he's
got drones coming out of his chest
please tell me about his kit yeah
similar to bloodhound
seer is all about tracking enemies but
in a different way and has a very unique
kit so while you're aiming down the
sights you'll have a heartbeat sensor
that will give you hints as to
where an enemy might be if you think
you've located them you can use your
tactical
which sends out some of those drones out
of your chest and will
actually reveal and track the enemy's
location the ultimate is really powerful
especially in certain gameplay
situations you can send out hundreds of
micro drones
and create a sphere around an area that
you choose and
all enemies that are moving quickly to
that space are tracked
i love when there's new abilities that
kind of change the game because this
game
obviously is always changing always
evolving and whenever there's a new
legend
there's always an interesting shift in
the meta so with those incredible
abilities how do you think that sears
going to change the game
yeah again i mentioned bloodhound also
as a tracker
but unlike bloodhound seer is about very
precise
and lingering information so he's a bit
more of a stealth oriented
legend and you're gonna see i think some
interactions because of that sphere i
mentioned his ultimate
if you're moving quickly through that
space your footsteps are revealed
ah but now if you're walking slowly you
can avoid
the the detection and so i think you'll
see some interesting gameplay
experiences and new ways to play
yeah with slowing it down a bit yeah it
sounds like once the ring gets tight
especially
you're gonna have a lot of new ways to
play this game
um but this past season for instance it
felt like apex really moved beyond
battle royale with the introduction of
arenas so what's the reaction been like
for you guys
the fan reaction has been really great
we've seen a lot of players
enjoy arenas which is which is awesome
we're really excited to finally have a
way to play apex legends beyond battle
royale
and uh yeah people are loving it so
we've got new maps in the works
and some other things come in i don't
want to just you know talk about just
yet
but we've got a lot planned for arenas
all right fair fair well
i do know that you guys announced ranked
arenas are coming as well so can you
give us some information on that
yep so we've got one season of arenas
under our belts now
we wanted to make sure that we were
seeing how players were adapting to the
mode
make sure to get the balance right make
sure that the the price and the economy
is correct
and now we'll be introducing the ranked
mode in emergence so it's a bit of a
different
ranked system than we have in in the
battle royale mode so we're really
excited for you to get your hands on it
well it's really cool to see apex always
doing new things like for instance
uh leaning into the competitive scene
with things like the apex legends global
series so are we gonna see more of the
algs
absolutely we just ended year one of
algs our championships recently
concluded and it was amazing there's
like so many tactics and
amazing plays in there many teams were
fighting for the championship in the
last round we hit record numbers
so we're really excited in september to
be kicking off year two of the lgs
and for the first time we're going to be
inviting playstation
and xbox players to compete alongside
the pc players really see who's best
and an all new league format so we have
more information at playapex.com
algs well i am beyond looking forward to
it and
chad before you go i have to ask
when can we see more from sear we've got
an awesome
gameplay trailer coming on monday
emergence drops on august 3rd
and for now i can show you a finisher of
course please
please
[Music]
this game demands so much of us
but from you she demands
everything that that's
that's all i need to see it's just it's
so awesome
but chad thank you so much for being
here thanks austin of course of course
and again big shout out to the whole
response